[Music]
we are back with mean dean in prescott
arizona sydney prescott hello sydney
what's up dean
hey uh john delany how you doing i'm
remarkable dean what's up
hey i had a question i was wondering how
do i better show my wife dignity and the
respect that she deserves
how are you not showing her dignity and
respect let's start there
well so
i grew up and my my parents got divorced
when i was about six and um
my dad isn't very respectful to
um just women in general whether it be
my stepmom my mom or my sisters how not
give me an example of how he's not
uh emotionally abusive verbally and just
um
yeah just manipulative and all the
narcissistic ways and things like that
so give me give me an example
um so i'm your mom and i was gonna i
was leaving early in the morning and i
said um hey i'm your stepmom and
i'm gonna go hang out with some friends
today and then i'll have dinner ready at
5 30. and then all sudden hanging out
with my friends turns into a couple of
drinks we have a great day and then two
friends show up and we haven't seen him
in a while and i don't get home till six
and your dad's at home at 5 30. what
does he say
uh that would have never happened
because of the fear of the
silent treatment and being
alienated
uh so he was a a he's silenced as a
weapon
yeah so like and like another thing for
about him is that um he sent me an email
about two years ago telling me that he
didn't want to talk to me or my siblings
anymore and he was justifying that my
parents like him cheating on my mom
originally was because he did it for her
so she could have a way out of the
relationship oh what a sweet guy
what a yeah right
a hero
so it sounds like your dad is trapped in
a nine-year-old brain and body
yeah i'd say so um and probably for a
thousand reasons i don't want to give
him a pass but he's a child
and he
just took his ball and i'm going home
yeah and when somebody says when the
when the teacher says why did you kick
timmy and he said
cause timmy wanted to go home so i just
kicked him so he could go home i mean
just he's a he's an elementary school
kid
yeah and so
he weaponized relationships that's what
happens when you use silence as a weapon
so you can hit somebody you can swear at
somebody or you can
cut ties and it's a
man i that that has been my weapon of
choice and it's evil man it's it's the
number one thing i'm working on in my
life
so
now you've got tell me about your kids
yeah so i have a two-year-old daughter
and a nine-month-old daughter
dude can we just stop for a second and
say high five to you brother what made
what made this come up what a stud man
that you looked at your dad and said i'm
not doing that
well it's been a long process and um
just being able to to see me and um
look at myself like third person and see
what i'm doing i could be doing better
to
uh change my family tree generationally
so i don't you know bro dude you're a
stud man that's incredible
is your uh did you marry will
yeah absolutely my wife is an absolute
angel and i definitely um i married up
for sure out kicked your coverage that's
awesome dude all right
so
is is there behaviors in yourself
that you recognize
and your goal and your first thought is
whoa i don't like that
yeah so i think that um especially in
our first little bit of marriage about
two years or so i would
i was you know dealing with a lot of my
own personal issues and so i would
um
i would also alienate myself because i
felt like i was hurting her or something
like that and so i would just kind of
leave
um like emotionally or physically just
for a little bit and it wasn't what she
needed and then also i think i just um
i those manipulative tendencies
tendencies
i would use
but i try to be acknowledge those things
and to not do it once that when i can
concede that i am doing something
manipulative very cool so
on the other side so now i'm gonna do
something that's gonna be uncomfortable
for you i'm gonna give your dad a quick
moment of grace
on the other side of his immaturity
that feeling when you start feeling like
i can't do anything right
and if i say anything else it's gonna
hurt my wife
so what i'm gonna do is turn the game on
and i'm gonna unplug to protect her from
me
and there's a
true like a real true i can see the
narrative in your dad's head
which is the best thing for me is if
they are not around me how do i blow
this up because i don't have the courage
to say hey i want to i want to leave
um or i want my kids to not be around me
because i'm not good so i'm going to
write them this immature letter and act
like does that make so your feelings are
it's the story you were born into with
your old man
right
oh man so here's man i got a little girl
so i'm just going to rattle off a few
things that i've struggled with and that
i'm wrestling with
and
um you jump in if anything sounds right
or
you think oh i like that okay
okay the first one is
always leaning into
when i think the world would be better
when i think my daughter or my son or my
wife would be better with me gone
i have to lean in the other way like a
salmon i gotta swim upstream of that
feeling
and i gotta do it quietly
and so often i try to when i gear myself
to come back and swim upstream so my
body is saying dude just get out of here
let me want you around so i go to hug my
daughter and she's like no dad no and my
first thought is yeah cause you suck at
being a dad
that's incorrect i don't i'm gonna
challenge that thought with evidence and
i don't suck at being a dad but my
five-year-old doesn't wanna me hugging
her or poking on her or making jokes at
five in the morning
so i'm gonna lean back into that
and i'm not gonna say anything
i might pat her on the head
or i might just touch her hand or i
might just sit down at the table and
drink my cup of coffee right across the
table from her so i'm going to lean into
that when my every impulse i have is to
run
because my kid my daughter's going to
internalize me running as she did
something
and i don't want to give her that much
power
she doesn't have that much power over me
she's five
same with my wife
there are times when i just want to
disappear like man i'm just gonna fine
and i'm not doing that anymore i'm gonna
lean and say out loud
my impulse is to pull away here because
i feel like i am i'm not saying the
right things
um
can you help me where are we
would your wife talk to you if you ask
her a question like that
oh absolutely okay absolutely so instead
of giving advice ask questions
okay not weapon questions either like
why are you wearing that or what's wrong
with you that's our weapon questions
those are bullcrap but
i feel like i'm missing the mark here
how can i best honor you right now
and let that's a risk because she may
say get the crap out of my get out of my
face and that could hurt but it's a risk
but we're gonna do that the second one
is to really be intentional about
respecting your daughter's bodies and
here's what i mean by that
my tennis i may have talked about this
on the show um i know i've talked about
it live
my
tendency
is i'll say hey josephine come give me a
hug
and she'll say no i don't want to
and my tendency is to use my dad powers
and to say i'm your dad i told you to do
a thing come do it now
and she will
begrudgingly because i'm dad i've got
bigger muscles than her i got power
but what i'm teaching her is
at some point some man will have
autonomy over your body
and they will get to tell you what to do
with your body and this turns into
that didn't hurt and she's saying yes it
did
and you're getting into her body and
telling her what her feelings are or you
shouldn't even be that sad i'm thinking
of her in middle school and the boy
breaks up with her
and someone she has a crush on just
dumps her and she's heartbroken and you
say ah just shake it off it's all good
that
teaches her body your feelings are not
to be trusted you need to find some man
that will
have your feelings for you
and so what i'm really combating in my
own self is when my daughter says that
hurt
i say i'm sorry that hurt now my first
thought is no it doesn't that didn't
hurt at all
or my first thought is when she says no
dad i say thank you for using kind words
and then i move on about my day because
that hug was for me not for her
so respecting their body
um and that goes into respecting their
thoughts and
man and then the last one here is
show up
just keep showing up and keep showing up
and keep showing up and if you can show
up with your little ones at eye level
get down on the floor and look them in
the eye
that gives them a sense of connection
that kind of equalizes that power
dynamic and it's really magical
especially with a young young young one
it's incredible oh i got one more
are you ready for this one
i think so
take care of yourself
exercise
have guy friends
um take go out once a week with your
buddies
and keep connected to them
have a life have a
spiritual life of some sort
um
get counseling if you need it you had a
lot of trauma growing up with an
immature dad and a divorce and all stuff
deal with that stuff
and come home whole
so your kids can have something to
anchor into
how's that okay that sounds perfect
sounds like a lot and love their mom
like crazy like crazy hug her a lot
if she's cool with that
kiss a lot be affectionate show her what
love looks like okay because you were
going to be the picture in your
daughter's mind of oh this is what a man
does this is what love looks like this
is what a romantic relationship looks
like
and um even if the the person they're
going to marry is nothing like you
you're given the picture of what that
looks like
um
but i think overall man the fact that
you're asking this question for a
two-year-old and a seven month old dude
you're so far ahead high five to you
anybody out there listening who had
parents who sucked or parents who were
going through their own stuff and didn't
show up or parents who wrote you a
letter and said i'm not being your
friend anymore whatever
man have the courage to turn and face
that storm because whatever you pass on
to your kids gets passed on to their
kids and and so on and so forth you have
the strength to turn and stop and say
this ends with me good for you good for
you dean from arizona my brother